listen Andy for the opposition this
morning good morning inflation figures
to start with thoughts on those I mean
catastrophic for a lot of people I'm
really really worrying we've still got
12 days to go until the chancellor is
going to bring forward new measures to
replace that catastrophic mini budget
that crashed the economy and send
people's mortgage payments through the
roof now you've got pensioners people on
benefits waiting to see what is going to
happen to them this is lives hanging in
the balance it's time this government
got grip reverse the mini budget in full
but calm back to the markets and brought
forward proposals to actually help
people this winter yeah that's the front
sector would say that's what they're
doing and that he also made the point
this morning we all make mistakes I mean
that this is one hell of a mistake
they've crashed the economy they've sent
mortgage payments and rent increases
through the roof we're still seeing that
huge volatility coming through interest
rates expected to rise again people just
can't take much more of this I don't any
sense having spent the last couple of
days in Parliament around Tory MPS
questioning the government that there is
any agreement amongst this divided party
about where to go next they started the
fire they sure aren't the people who are
going to go and put it out yeah but if
you took over tomorrow uh labor
government you'd still have all of these
issues we would have one of the worst
economic situations that any government
has inherited and we've been really
clear that there would be no magic wand
but what we would do is make fairer
choices asking those with the broader
shoulders to Bear the greatest burden
when you've got the chief executive well
when you've got the chief executive of
shell saying taxes more it Beggars
belief that the government is still
dragging its feet the oil and gas
producers have made big profits we think
we should expand the windfall tax to
help more people we think we should
scrap non-dom status to raise money to
invest in the National Health Service to
help the million people who are on
currently on waiting list instead you've
got a government that is mooting more
cuts for the NHS and raising taxes on
working people it's just unconscionable
Jeremy Hunters said that he is looking
at a windfall tax he said nothing's off
the table well he said nothing's off the
table but unfortunately for the country
at the moment nothing's on the table
either the government has been following
uh admitted belatedly some of the
proposals that we've made just a few
weeks ago Liz trust was mocking the
labor party for not setting out two-year
plans on energy and instead setting out
six months plans there now they've
accepted that it's better to set out
properly costed six-month plans that you
can actually deliver for people than it
is to just play Fantasy economics and
play fast and loose with people's money
that's what we want to see from the
chancellor in 12 days time properly
costed plans that they can actually
deliver with working people currently
paying the price for the crisis that was
made in Downing Street
um would you put income tax
we we'd like to see that we we supported
the top rate of tax returning to the
level that it was at previously because
we think it's wrong to cut taxes for the
wealthiest at a time when people are
really struggling but and we'd like to
see taxes on working people come down
but we wouldn't support unfunded
uncosted measures because in the end
it's those same people who pay the price
we've seen that with mortgage payments
they've gone up by an eye-watering 500
pounds on average a month since the
Tories crashed the economy with a huge
package of unfunded borrowing
commitments and we're not going to make
that same mistake everything that we set
out will be fully costed ahead of the
next election would you go higher than
45p in the pound well we look we think
we think those with the broader
shoulders should bear the greatest
burden but yes you know we supported
keeping the top rate of income tax we
said that we would reverse the cut we've
been completely consistent on that and
we're not planning to change that
position now
um but we will set out proper measures
ahead of the next general election we
have no idea what economic situation
we're going to inherit in 2024 at this
stage the government is still gagging
the office of budget responsibility
they're not allowing them to publish
their impact assessment or forecasts we
think that's wrong Jeremy Hill is
committed to bringing that forward let's
see that as quickly as possible so that
we can get on with making plans to
repair the damage that the Tories have
done so could we see 50p in the parent
and for um top rate of tax tempting as
it is okay I'm not going to write a
budget for the next Labor government
live on Sky although I'm sure that you
guys would be the first to know once we
have it's really important that we're
careful with people's money we've seen
what happens when you're not and this is
their money not ours people don't have a
lot of it at the moment and we're going
to be careful with every penny when we
set out commitments when we set out how
we're going to raise money as well as
how we're going to spend money we're
going to show people that we've thought
that through and that we can stick to it
and that we can actually deliver last
time you're in power you weren't no I
mean I remember the note I'm sure it
still haunts you as a labor there's no
money left with the note well no but
there was no money left anywhere in the
world because we had a global financial
crash and if we didn't if we hadn't had
Gordon Brown in 10 Downing Street at the
time things could have been
substantially worse that bailout package
helped assure up people's pensions and
their life savings you remember the cues
outside Northern Rock people were
panicking they were terrified and we
brought stability back to the system
that's the opposite of what this
government's done they've crushed the
system and we're coming back to try and
win back the trust of people to govern
in order that we can repair that damage
again as guessing the government would
say that that's exactly what this man
has done um Jeremy Hunt he's studied the
nerves Jeremy Hunt is the person who sat
in every cabinet over the last 12 years
this morning and helped to get this
country into this mess he brought the
National Health Service to its easy
presided over huge amounts of waste in
the National Health Service they didn't
invest it to help make the NHS more
productive in capacity and buildings in
digital digitalization of services and
as a consequence we're all paying the
price this is a man who is responsible
for a lot of the damage that has been
done over the last 12 years he's not the
person who's going to set it right how
worried are we about the fact that Ben
Wallace has gone to Washington used to
be a shadow foreign didn't you he's gone
to Washington suggestions are that there
are deep concerns about what Putin is
doing with his nuclear Armory
I think the whole situation in Russia is
incredibly worrying I think it's right
of Ben Wallace and the government to
stand shoulder to shoulder with our NATO
allies we fully support them in that and
we also think as Ben Wallace reportedly
thinks that if Jeremy Hunt is trying to
cut funding for defense at a time when
we're engaged in dealing with enormous
Russian aggression and the very
unpredictable actions of a of an
authoritarian leader in our own
neighborhood that would be the wrong
thing to do and if Ben Wallace wants to
have that fight with his own party we of
course will stand with him in order to
try and win that okay and what would you
um say to I I also put it to the foreign
secretary it was pointed out to me
yesterday that we do need to do
something because he's a Madman with
nukes well I mean you know I learned
during the time that I served a Shadow
Forest secretary that you don't inflame
situations you try to calm them down and
diplomacy is always better
the situation yeah how do you use
diplomacy with Putin well you can't and
that's why we've got to use the
Diplomatic tools that we've got to stand
with our closest neighbors across Europe
and not be divided to stand with our
NATO allies and not be divided that's
where we need to focus our efforts in
order to put up a strong firm united
front against Russian aggression and
show Putin that you just can't win okay
it's always a pleasure thankfully thank
you thank you